et on va se focaliser sur ce déplacement
donc à venir de vladimazelenski qui est
attendu en fin d'après-midi heure
française à Washington bonjour nicole
Bacharan et merci de répondre à nos
questions vous êtes historienne et
politologue spécialiste de la politique
et de la société américaine c'est un
joli coup diplomatique pour Joe Biden
d'abord oui bien sûr mais c'est
magnifique des deux côtés c'est même
très émouvant je dois le dire vous savez
que l'Amérique aime les héros et s'il y
a s'il y a un héros de notre temps c'est
volody mirzelinski le fait qu'il quitte
son pays qu'il entreprennent ce voyage
pour s'adresser directement au président
et au parlementaire américain ça montre
à la fois son courage son besoin d'avoir
de l'aide de supplémentaire et puis
également pour Joe Biden évidemment ça
rappelle parce que c'est un fait connu
de tous que Joe Biden et le chef
occidental de cette guerre
la prise de parole de volodières zellens
qui au Congrès ça c'est un honneur qui
est réservé à certaines personnalités
pas à toutes oui absolument à peu peu de
gens peu de responsables politiques
étrangers quand ça se produit c'est
vraiment l'un des plus grands honneurs
que les États-Unis puissent offrir un
visiteur étranger vous l'avez rappelé
dans le sujet
a déjà parlé au Congrès virtuellement là
il vient les voir en chair et en os si
j'ose dire face à face et on peut
s'attendre à ce que tous les
parlementaires soient là et ce que
l'innovation qui terminera son discours
soit encore plus nourri que quand il
était à distance parce qu'on reconnaît
son courage les risques qu'il prend et
l'urgence qu'il y a qu'il y a à l'écouté
à répondre à ses attentes il y a le côté
symbolique vous le disiez c'est aussi
une visite
de gros sous au final puisque les
Américains ont déjà dégagé 20 milliards
de dollars d'aide militaire Ukrainiens
sont comptés la dualité logistique
nicole Bacharan est-ce que les
républicains sont d'accord pour
débloquer autant d'argent eux qui
prendront le contrôle de la Chambre des
représentants dans quelques jours une
partie des républicains n'est pas
d'accord et c'est ce que l'on peut
qualifier sans exagérer les élus
d'extrême droite à la chambre ils sont
pas très nombreux mais ils peuvent quand
même
s'exprimer même plombé un peu les votes
futures ce sont des gens qui poussent ce
qui appuie sur les bases instincts j'ai
envie de dire populiste simplifie en
tout et simplifiant tout pardon et
disons en gros ben non notre argent
c'est pour le peuple américain on est au
service des peuples américains et que le
peuple ukrainien au fond ne soit pas
phase n'est pas notre premier n'est pas
notre premier souci donc ça sera
peut-être plus compliqué après le 3
janvier quand ces nouveaux élus seront à
la Chambre des Représentants mais
au-delà de ça il y a quand même un
consensus large entre les deux parties
pour soutenir l'Ukraine pour voir que
c'est quand même l'intérêt des
démocraties de ne pas laisser cette
terre avec la lumière Poutine les
Américains qui devraient livrer on
attend une confirmation des missiles
patriotes des missiles que demande de
longue date les
Ukrainiens qu'est-ce qui pousse les
Américains à accentuer le raid est-ce
qu'il craignent une nouvelle offensive
des Russes sur la capitale ils craignent
une nouvelle offensive en surveille
beaucoup ce qui se passe du côté de de
la Biélorussie mais même dans l'immédiat
la protection aérienne antimissiles elle
se récruciale ça prendra du temps avant
que les patriotes soient en action il
faut entraîner les Ukrainiens à s'en
servir ça peut prendre jusqu'à plusieurs
mois mais il s'agit de protéger riposter
à la guerre contre le peuple ukrainien
qui est mené par Vladimir Poutine
Elena rappelé les conditions dans
laquelle la population vit en plein
hiver avec des températures glaciales
sans électricité sans eau dans le noir
c'est une véritable guerre contre les
civils c'est vraiment
infligé énormément de souffrance et il y
aura beaucoup de morts les personnes
fragiles les personnes malades
âgées les bébés sont vraiment menacés
par cette guerre du froid donc tenter de
protéger l'espace aérien ukrainien c'est
devenu absolument indispensable ça
l'était déjà ça l'est plus encore en
hiver il y a toutefois des armes que Joe
Biden se refusent à livrer de peur que
les Ukrainiens ciblent la Russie que le
conflit s'étendent exactement vous
l'avez vu notamment des missiles de
longue portée qui pourraient pénétrer
loin dans le territoire russe au fond la
question de la cobelligérance la
question de la ligne rouge elle a
toujours été à Vladimir Poutine c'est il
a tout à fait assez d'éléments pour dire
aux américain vous êtes obligérant et
aux Européens également et on voit qu'il
recule parce qu'il a pas envie il a pas
la capacité d'affronter directement
l'OTAN mais les Américains jouent avec
cette ligne fournissant des armes de
plus en plus sophistiquée de plus en
plus efficace tout en testant la
résistance du Kremlin la résistance du
Kremlin s'est égard donc
quand on est à
ukrainien quand on voit les missiles qui
partent du territoire russe et qui
détruisent toutes les infrastructures la
tentation est très forte d'aller frapper
les bases militaires d'où partent ces
missiles et les Américains tentent de
contenir ça pour ne pas aller plus loin
dans la déflagration en Europe une
dernière question sur l'état d'esprit de
l'opinion américaine ça fait 300 jours
que la guerre a commencé est-ce qu'il y
a une certaine lassitude qui s'installe
oui il y a une lassitude il y a une
inquiétude combien de temps ça va durer
ça coûte extrêmement cher est-ce que ça
peut finir très très mal avec un
adversaire comme comme Vladimir Poutine
le soutien il est à peu près
moitié-moitié moitié pour moitié contre
à moitié contre continuer à comment dire
ne pas conclure la guerre rapidement et
puis une moitié pour qui dit non il faut
il faut continuer il faut continuer tant
que ce sera nécessaire et la visite de
Zelinski va avoir un impact quand on
voit le courage de cet homme les risques
qu'il prend évidemment tout ce qu'il va
animer des grandes valeurs américaines
de sacrifices d'amour de sa patrie
d'héroïsme c'est aussi pour convaincre
l'opinion américaine qu'il faut tenir
discours à suivre et rencontres avec Joe
Biden sur France 24 merci beaucoup
nicole Bacharan nous avons éclairé sur
cette